no
quedan abiertas
pero no
hola qué tal
bienvenidos claro que es bienvenido
porque de todas formas estamos en
facebook live y bien
vamos tenemos acá un pequeño problema
técnico pero más no obstante vamos a
tratar de solucionarlo en toda forma
pues nuestra técnica está batallando ahí
para que podamos grabar el programa de
este viernes 2 de marzo que está
saliendo en vivo en ti y en directo por
facebook live cuál es la cámara de la
cámara
ok entonces en vivo y en directo por
facebook live el castor cibernético pero
que también está en vivo y en directo en
youtube y en nuestro sitio internet
rc y net punto sea no es así dicen los
que saben que les recordamos que la
versión
audio de este programa la podrán
escuchar también en el sitio internet
rc y net punto o sea el viernes este
viernes 2 de marzo del sábado 3 y el
domingo 4 de marzo esta versión tendrá
la música agregada
esta semana está a cargo del conocido
grupo de montreal simple plan y que no
escucharemos acá en el programa en
facebook live porque la técnica no nos
lo permite así es justamente es que
facebook es por una cuestión de derechos
de autor como no sabes dónde viene a
dónde va esa música es como las eretas
exacto entonces no nos permite la
difusión de piezas musicales dentro de
su alive bueno un caluroso saludo a
todos y todas allá en el ciberespacio
y gracias por su agradable compañía
leonora chapman luis laborda leonardo
gimeno bienvenidos
muchísima gente cercado por la tripe la
triple l argentina acá bueno no suele
suceder muy a menudo pero bueno pues de
vez en cuando
también tenemos visita hoy acá en el
castor cibernético tenemos la visita del
escritor y académico
no canadiense leandro josé leandro
urbina para la necesidad del programa lo
vamos a llamar simplemente leandro
bienvenido a leandro decidas bueno y con
un leandro vamos a conversar en el
transcurso del programa y para no perder
las costumbres porque al parecer tenemos
viejas costumbres siempre entonces este
castor cibernético lo vamos a comenzar
con alguna noticia o algo inédito que
haya atraído su atención esta semana
quien se lanza primer bond yo en
realidad no están inéditos pero lo que
me llamó la atención es que se cumplen
esta semana se cumplieron 10 años de que
la red social 'facebook' hizo la
traducción al español hace 10 años ya
que la plataforma de esa red social
existe en español y particularmente lo
interesante es que fue la segunda lengua
que fue la segunda lengua a ser
habilitada dentro de esta plataforma
bueno era inteligente entonces sí bueno
sabía que zuckerberg o américa
es la segunda lengua de eeuu
o sea evidentemente estaba tratando de
captar ese público y lo hizo y lo hizo
muy bien así que aquí estamos festejando
10 años de plataforma en español en
español pero la plataforma facebook como
tal lleva cuánto tiempo deben ser 16 17
años fíjate qué tiempo bueno dijiste que
das una calurosa bienvenida y creo que
sí que es caluroso se está haciendo
calor lo cual llama lección en montreal
mismo afuera
está mejor me digo hoy está mejor pero
ayer estaba haciendo 6 grados en el
norte en groenlandia cuando tendría que
estar haciendo 40 bajo cero entonces hay
una preocupación bastante seria de los
científicos los climatólogos que están
viendo que lo que está pasando en europa
es muy raro también unos fríos extremos
ya hay más de 50 muertos mientras que
acá estamos con transpirando estábamos
hasta ayer con el mes de no terminaba en
terminaba el mes de febrero es uno de
los más fríos y lo que sorprende por
ejemplo es que en una isla como de
córcega es casi caía nieve no cabría jr
entonces era antes de ayer y estaba
viendo un poco de estadía de
medioambiente canadá que es un experto
que decía de qué
acá estaban dando medidas que
temperaturas cálidas cerca del polo
norte en invierno se registraron 4 entre
1980 y 2010 es decir en 30 años hubo
cuatro períodos temperaturas cálidas
mientras que ahora durante el invierno
si en mientras claro hubo cuatro en
cinco años entonces es algo que está
preocupando muchísimo y decía este
experto que es phillips hablando de
nunavut que dice que sea literalmente se
ha destrozado el récord anterior en una
bud estaba haciendo siete grados bajo
cero cuando el récord era de 30 bajo
cero en el mismo periodo entonces ahí es
algo que que dicen que además lo que
preocupa es que no es algún hecho
aislado sino es una tendencia que se
está manifestando cada vez más entonces
el hielo se está derritiendo en el norte
y el frío se está manifestando en el sur
y ahí hay un problema o sea con que haga
calor bueno pues no nos vamos a quejar
pero en el nunavut el problema es que el
permafrost se descongela y eso pues pone
en peligro todas las estructuras
duras que están a los edificios en 50
años no va a haber hielo en el polo
norte bueno a tener que cambiar de
ingeniería civil es que se está haciendo
eso el problema es lo las consecuencias
de eso habrá que adaptarse pero si no
van a ver costas que van a desaparecer
casi totalmente las subidas de los
océanos en belo no hay cambio climático
pero sí hay costas también hay costos
louis de borda bueno ya que hablábamos
del clima y de nieve me me hizo recordar
esto un paisaje que vi por televisión de
otro día de gran bretaña mientras se
jugaba un partido de fútbol como caía la
nieve en un lugar en el que la nieve no
suele caer de manera tan abundante es
decir europa entera está sufriendo la
consecuencia de este cambio climático y
vayan a contarle a ellos que no existe
ahora ligado a esto ya que hablamos de
de estas cuestiones que nos llama la
atención viviendo precisamente un
partido de fútbol y tratándose este de
una muy bolero como siempre
inglaterra inglés tratándose de un año
en el que se va a jugar el mundial de
fútbol
en el cual se aplicó el famoso bar no el
bar donde uno va a tomar unos tragos
cuando el vídeo
sirve para controlar ahora para ver a
córner
se supone que son tres jugadas
definitivas o jugadas que pueden ayudar
al árbitro a no cometer injusticias
no sirve para la interpretación del
árbitro sobre el vídeo un partido de
copa de las que se juegan en europa y
jugaba el tottenham un equipo de
inglaterra que está dirigido por un
argentino mauricio pochettino y el
tottenham que terminó ganando de todas
maneras a uno en un partido bastante
interesante el árbitro gracias al bar le
anuló tres goles
por ejemplo que después en el vídeo se
veía que estaban perfectamente
habilitado a los jugadores para cometer
esos goles y lo que me llamó mucho la
atención fue que cada vez que había una
jugada que no sé por qué al réferi le
parecía que podía hacer de día que tenía
al partido tenía una religión que estaba
estrenando maquinita perdió si los
árbitros en torneos de primordial
olvídate por aparte tienen una cuestión
de tiempos de difusión o sea tienen que
respetar exactamente los tiempos la
función comercial y porque en realidad
las transmisiones del mundial están
vendidas todo el mundo
el señor que para el partido 50 ventas
estudiando tú tendrías algo así que haya
atraído tu atención esta semana acá en
montreal yo sé que te estás despacio
pero bueno sí pero que hay montones no
sé en la mañana estaba mirando más del
micro estaba mirando en el diario y
aparecía en la noticia de que trump
empezó hoy día a tuitear a las cinco y
media de la mañana se ve tele todo el
día
trabajo está trabajándose bueno y a mí
lo que me llamó la atención es una
noticia económica
reciente en el salario
[Música]
no tiene que pedir aumento sólo dan
solos así que bueno pero se presentó el
presupuesto federal esta semana sí y no
lo voy a hablar de las cifras del
presupuesto federal porque eso no nos
importa pero bueno entre las medidas que
contiene este presupuesto figura el
anuncio de la muerte bueno de la muerte
digo yo del retiro de los billetes de
mil dólares de la circulación
esa es la razón esa es una de las
razones
retiro del billete en particular de mil
dólares porque retiraron otros retiraron
al de uno el de 21 de 25 que ni siquiera
sabía que existía odio insistió y el de
500 pero el de 1000 lo retira porque la
policía no hay 740 mil en circulación en
este momento todavía en la actualidad en
todo canadá en todo canadá y 740 mil 500
de esos tiene eso yo nunca bueno vi una
vez alguien que me lo mostró de lejos y
eso fue todo
y una de las razones es porque la
policía federal la gendarmería real de
canadá pidió que se retirara para en el
marco de la lucha contra el lavado de
dinero la lucha contra el narcotráfico y
la falsificación de billetes porque
además de eso porque le permite a los
criminales desplazar grandes sumas de
dinero un poco en poco espacio en poco
volumen entonces una de las formas de
pelear contra de luchar contra la
criminalidad es justamente pues de
disminuir la posibilidad de que lo
puedan hacer y sacándoles el billete de
ameal que le facilita la vuelta de un
dólar
[Risas]
leonardo hay alguna reacción en facebook
que de nuestra gente
bueno mientras tanto pues leona tesl
nuestro nuestro invitado josé leandro
urbina leandro bienvenido a radio al
canal internacional
vernet y muchas gracias leandro tú lo
decimos tú eres chileno de nacimiento el
golpe de estado en chile en el 73 te
llevo a argentina y estuviste es ahí en
una época en argentina después más tarde
en el 77 saliste de argentina para acá
para canadá cuéntanos un poco cómo fue
esa llegada como fue esa salida como lo
viviste tu ese ese golpe que te llevó a
digo a buenos aires y después a montreal
que recordar es bueno en mi familia
participaba en política y entonces el
mismo día 11 de septiembre el día del
golpe allanaron mi casa y hoy yo yo soy
el mayor de esa familia con mi hermano
segundo salimos por los tejados de la
casa
bueno mi padre estuvo preso en el
estadio nacional en chile etcétera y dos
de mis hermanos pequeños también y llegó
un momento en que había que salir y yo
con buen olfato político salía argentina
argentina buenos aires seguía buenos
aires y bueno ya el primer día me
pararon en la calle y
documentos sí exacto y bueno
la experiencia argentina fue increíble
porque por otra parte fue una
experiencia muy interesante para mí me
sentía muy provinciano viniendo de
santiago buenos aires
y yo me habría quedado buenos aires si
hubiera sido posible pero no fue posible
llegó un momento en que ya después del
golpe de videla
y ya las situaciones
estabas en buenos aires en aquella época
estuve yo estaba en mi lugar de donde
había nacido en el norte argentino
cuando fue el golpe en santiago del
estero pero fui a buenos aires como
salida argentina pase por buenos aires
pero no vivía en buenos han coincidido
de alguna forma yo estaba en buenos
aires en esa época yo estuve viviendo en
buenos aires del 72 al 74 sí demostrando
también muy buen olfato
una cosa así yo en el 32 y lo estaban
haciendo
[Risas]
[Música]
y de montreal
y a ver yo fui primero a ottawa
buenos aires
y luego me vine a casa y también fue muy
divertida o sea me gustaría vivir en
montreal
pero me mandaron a ottawa entonces yo
pensaba que había que ser obediente y
con papeles y han destilado está bueno
pero siempre he viajado mucho a muchas
tengo amigos grandes y no viviste como
tal
montreal mucho
en esa época te digo en el año 77
tomarse un expreso de máquina había
había que ir a un lugar un lugar que era
de lógica
en el bronx aunque había una cola de
mañana y dentro estaba repleto y tomaban
café así con tratando en este caso me
pasó exactamente lo mismo y yo decía
este café parece aguas sucias y grandes
de agua sucia sí pero bueno ahora este
es un café que tomo aquí en el trabajo
cotidianamente así que llama me quería
fuerte
[Música]
era terrible y leonardo ahora si quería
haber conseguido y nos dice que las
américas café muchos saludos amigos aquí
iniciando mi visita semanal del programa
muchos saludos a leandro así que
un amigo de méxico
bueno y tú
leandro entre otras cosas esa historia
una parte de la historia acá en canadá
en ella y en montreal también porque ahí
está esta novela que se llama a cobro
revertido que explica de alguna forma
una parte de la vida del personaje no o
sea que no no no es autobiográfico pero
bueno me imagino que te inspiraste de
alguna forma de en lo que el exilio
representó para para esta comunidad
chilena que estaba aquí en montreal este
cobro revertido sí sí está establecido
en montreal en montreal sí bueno porque
tal como te digo una ciudad mucho más
ancha tenía hacia el escenario haber
puesto de agua de escenario agregamos
con él saliendo de un ministerio
llegando a otro
en esa época era como un como una casa
de reposo así como un gran hospital si
uno pasea por los jardines está bonito
este pero no había mucha vitalidad
aclaremos por la gente que no conoce
nada mal con agua pero es muy bonita
a las cuatro de la tarde cuando todo el
mundo salió de los ministerios parece sí
manhattan sería las cuatro y veinte y no
queda nadie no haría exactamente
exactamente y no lo hay
hablamos de vida nocturna haber cambiado
un poco
lo más interesante interesante y ha
cambiado por el impacto de la
inmigración no inmigrante
mucho tiempo me sorprendió ver la
cantidad de frutas verduras activamente
sur que antes eso era impensable si yo
ahora por ejemplo con la llegada a los
sirios
tú ves que hay los supermercados han
crecido ahí mucha fruta mucha verdura
porque ellos parecen que consumen mucho
es hoy interesante ver cómo la y miguel
propio general ha traído nuevos
productos nuevos restaurantes y será una
actividad pues exacta muy distinta a la
que había antes y regresando entonces al
cobro revertido sin querido leandro
háblanos un poco de cobro revertido es
la historia del sociólogo que le llama
no y bueno como como como es la historia
del sociólogo si lo que pasa que cobró
ósea
cuando en montreal yo veía los grupos de
chilenos bastante perdidos o sea el
golpe fue un golpe realmente con un
golpe en la cabeza si las posibilidades
de retomar la vida pasando por encima
del trauma de todo eso no era tan fácil
entonces tú dirías cada cosa qué
era tragicómico casi en todo el trayecto
de la comunidad
y todos muy pegados con hablar y hablar
y hablar de chile o sea todo todas las
conversiones chile y que va a pasar y
estoy va a venir de apuestas y poco te
sigue etcétera o sea de la casi
enfermiza la cosa nadie daba vuelta a la
página digamos entonces eso era digamos
como material como material novelable
además de las de las relaciones que se
establecían con los extranjeros como
decían los canadienses
entonces es bueno ver pereza es ese tipo
de escenario con combinaciones con el
afuera y el adentro era realmente
y divertido divertido muy frívolo pero
llamativo por los meses y si tienen
alguna pregunta para leandro en lo que
me interesaba que empezamos a ver un
poco de eso antes de iniciar el programa
es y la visión del chile actual sí
bueno hay esa novela una novela de
exilio donde el tipo del personaje
quiere ir al entierro de su madre y ha
muerto pero nunca llega o sea nunca sale
de monte al que se da vuelta y vuelta y
vuelta y nunca sale pero tiene muchas
ganas
de realmente y repente pero se queda
pegado en algún barrio en alguna ahora y
yo creo que la evolución del chile
qué pasa por el fin de la dictadura
y toda la
lo que fue el recuperar la democracia
como decían en todo ese proceso
fue un proceso que para muchos chilenos
fue bastante decepcionante y sobre todo
los logros de cada que volvían volvía
muchos a chile pensando que iban a
recuperar algo de la anterior pero el
panorama era completamente distinto las
fuerzas políticas funcionaban de manera
distinta etcétera y muchos de ellos
fueron incluso con dinero adquiriendo
instalarse allá y al final se volvieron
y acá yo
acaso no eran distintos de ellos también
claro por supuesto pero digamos había
una manera de ser chileno que le traían
de atrás o sea y un poco
probablemente no reconocían plenamente
cuánto habían cambiado ellos también las
cuentas pero en en cuanto a ser chileno
usaban más bien el l el guión de la
película anterior encuentro porque creo
que eso tiene es una tendencia del
inmigrante en general cuando uno vuelve
después de tres o cuatro o cinco diez
dependiendo la cantidad de años uno se
mantiene en el imaginario el lugar de
donde se fue como cuando se fue
si uno crece el lugar crece las personas
crecen las personas cambian los lolos
los estímulos cambian entonces uno nos
cambia absolutamente y vuelve y pretende
esa persona que ya cambio volver y que
todo esté en aquel momento cuando es
imposible en realidad no sé si se
preguntaba también si escribiste sobre
eso el chile post refugio exilio
que escribiste sobre bueno el último
libro o un libro que se llama derrumbe
que es un libro de cuentos que es un
poco sobre como yo persigo el chile de
ahora
pero un proyecto mayor que tengo que es
un proyecto de memorias del varón y que
es un personaje ficticio y un intento de
registrar un poco lo que fue chile en
los años 60-70 que en realidad se borró
y eso desde eso no lo quiera muchas
huellas en la literatura
ni siquiera históricamente
y la vida cotidiana no está representada
o sea los acontecimientos políticos sí
pero lo que fueron las generaciones de
jóvenes que fueron en esa época digamos
a la escuela porque se podía ir a la
escuela de todas las revoluciones
sexuales y de todo tipo no cierto ballet
la participación política que se
incrementó indudablemente en los
sectores juveniles y todo eso no está
arrestado entonces yo he tratado un poco
estoy tratando de registrar eso es la
saga de varones y creo que vamos a
regresar con la saga de varón y leonardo
gimeno acá supongo que es nuestro
fantasma porque pública radio canadá
internacional nuestro fantasma es el
querido ruso valencia que está en viaje
a toronto dice desde el tren a toronto
un saludo a leandro en esta ciudad él
participó en el primero y último número
de la revista quiebre del mexicano juan
escareño y del peruano alex sismo
ese es el mensaje de rufo valència que
está en viajes a la pura verdad es la
pura verdad y bueno pues vamos a leer
algunos justamente mensajes de nuestros
oyentes y regresamos a leandro en poco
tiempo el luis laborda si tengo aquí un
mensaje que envía a nelson ricardo
cepeda ribera sobre el tema enfermos con
fibrosis quística bien más tiempo en
canadá que en cualquier país de las
américas y él dice buenas tardes vivo en
el salvador mi hija fue diagnosticada
con figuras y crítica estamos haciendo
todo para que mi bebé sobreviva como
puede hacer para optar a un programa de
atención a pacientes con fibrosis
quística es la pregunta en el sindicado
se pueda liberar
si acá tengo un comentario sobre
negociaciones difíciles en la séptima
ronda de conversaciones del tlcan nos
escribe javier gonzález nungaray y dice
amigos drs y el castor cibernético esto
se pone calentito pero a la vez
emocionante en lo que respecta al sector
automotriz en esta ronda del tlc dijo
lalo gonzález el piporro que no sé si me
vamos a ver si sé
un acuerdo yo espero que si yo sí les
comento estoy muy interesado en que el
tlc llegue a buen puerto saludos a todos
leonardo sirve no un pequeño mensaje
aquí de efrén rodríguez sobre el tema
españa vigila sus fronteras ante
posibles retorno del líder catalán
carles pulmón y dice dios bendiga
apoyemos y lo corona con la victoria en
sus propósitos bueno y miren miren que
tenemos que son casi como los billetes
de 1.000 el proceso rarísima de recibir
correo aéreo y bueno yo no sé si se van
a enterar pero vamos a acusar la
recepción desde la casa porque bueno yo
no sé escribe todavía algunos hacen
alusión todavía a la onda corta
bueno y ya hace casi cinco años y medio
van a ser seis años ahora en el mes de
junio próximo el 24 de junio que ya no
estamos más en la onda corta y bueno
pero nos escriben todavía amigos desde
desde cuba y tenemos acá a tania
espinoza pérez quien nos escribe desde
holguín tenemos una carta también de
justina amarilla saldívar saldívar de
holguín cuba también podar y álvarez
peña desde bayamo vayamos o vayamos
siempre que estábamos con la cubana
vaya vaya vaya vaca bueno desde bayamo
granma nos escribía o danny álvarez peña
después el alguien dirige al club amigos
de canadá maricel guilarte tanto tanto
tanto maricel quilate
y ella nos escribe desde guantánamo y
escribe al club de amigos de canadá
ahora imagínate entonces quiere decir de
qué todavía esos son viejos recuerdos de
historias del club de amigos era un
espacio específico que había en el sitio
bueno ex tenía un programa donde se leen
las cartas del club de amigos y uno
había hablado con el club de amigos de
radio canadá en cuba
exacto pero eso ya no existe supongo no
existía
eso cuando cortamos la onda corta ellos
seguían existiendo pero después no
tuvimos más noticias sí exacto y tenemos
otra carta que nos viene desde el paso
texas y nos la envía luis camarillo
entonces pues tenemos correspondencia
correo aéreo que está muy bien que no es
poco' ahora como ya estamos en la época
del texto y del correo electrónico
también prehistoria dice nada está por
desaparecer bueno quiero desaparecer la
transforman se transforman en envío de
paquetes por las sombras en internet
hay negocios físicos que están
desapareciendo y una juguetería super
popular en eeuu que tenía cientos y
cientos de locales en todo eeuu canadá
la compañía que está creando su propio
servicio ahora de entre partes dejando
de lado a las compañías existentes parte
extra planean de una cosa bastante rara
bastante en el nivel de la locura que
sin plata no no no no es que uno le da
la autorización y si uno se abona un
servicio específico de amazon amazon
instala una cerradura en la casa del
cliente para entrar dejarle el paquete
adentro y cerrar puertas para evitar que
haya que se lo roben en la puerta porque
ahora es muy eficiente pero pasan y
dejan el paquete y se van o sea que se
están expuestos no yo no le doy la llave
de mi claro que eso es dejar entre todos
conocido que entre es un paquete a ver
si dejan un micrófono y van dejando
cosas
registrados de computadora dejan cosas
comprometedoras entonces prometida y esa
remera y esa blusa de quién es la de
joel de hambre un regalo de acción ahora
te digo esto comparado con eeuu nada yo
vi bien en washington en una época
después del 11 de septiembre de allá y
los sistemas de vigilancia eran
increíbles increíbles entraban a tu casa
se entrevistaron a un tipo que había ido
a mirar esas esas tecnologías y el tipo
que manejaba dice a ver donde vive
estuvo en qué calle es tal
en qué difícil that
en qué piso alto
tú tienes un gato
la cámara entraba por la ventana del
tipo el departamento o sea todavía aquí
no hemos llegado a eso los televisores
que ya venían con una cámara lo que
llama la atención es que las gran parte
de los personajes no no pero los grandes
personajes de las dueñas de empresas de
comunicaciones y cuestiones así en sus
aparatos personales tienen tapas de las
cámaras claro visible y sobre eso
también es cierto o sea cuando uno le
hace una entrevista a zuckerberg y uno
ve que en la laptop de zuckerberg tiene
un pedazo de cinta negra no es porque
como dudoso digamos porque su cartera
vende pero esa persona ellos dicen que a
su hijo no lo deja jugar con un juego
electrónico
por eso sí bueno para beneficio tuyo
leandro este programa que ahora estamos
llamando el castor cibernético y la
razón por la cual estas cartas todavía
siguen llegando así es que durante la
época en que teníamos en nuestro
programa salía por la onda corta
teníamos un programa que se llamaba el
castor mensajero y antes de eso creo que
era amigos de la correspondencia o algo
así tenía otro nombre de estaciones
actualización a la correspondencia se
llamaba antes y quizá tenía otro nombre
bueno porque hay quiere decir que radio
canadá internacional existe desde hace
72 años no se hace cierto tiempo
entonces teníamos ese programa que
nosotros en un momento dado
llamamos bautizamos el castor mensajero
que era el intercambio con los oyentes
que ahora están ese intercambio lo
hacemos acá por intermedio de facebook
live y nos escriben directamente en
aquella época pues nos enviaban cartas y
bueno con nosotros 80 ya veíamos un
programa estrictamente sobre las cartas
y sobre el intercambio con nuestros
oyentes entonces pues eso
digamos que esa tradición por llamarlo
de alguna forma quedó y cuando ya
entramos nosotros acá en la era
cibernética en a partir del 2012 del 25
de junio porque cortaron la onda contra
la onda corta el domingo 24 de junio y
el lunes 25 estábamos trabajando ya en
internet entonces pues bueno decidimos
pues en el equipo y todo que era
interesante pues seguir ese contacto con
los oyentes y tenemos ahora acá el
castor cibernético que lo ponemos desde
hace ya como cuánto tiempo en facebook
live
casi casi tres años y tres años que
estamos en facebook live
tres años dos años dos a dos años sí
aquí tengo un mensaje de gilberto
martínez e saludo cara de las américas
café felicitó al invitado que habla de
elekta duro en chile y dice que nos dice
de las nuevas dictadores de los nueve
dictadores de américa latina bueno
entonces hay una pregunta para ti
quiénes serían los dictadores eso lo
escrito
argentina fue elegido democráticamente
sí pero las formas de gobierno son las
que dictan digamos la forma la forma de
la política
y yo creo que
bueno uno puede decir que en venezuela
también lo eligieron democráticamente
y yo creo que las nuevas formas que está
adoptando la lectura ya no necesitan el
respaldo militar pero no necesitan la
presencia digamos en la calle de los
militares ni a los militares en el
gobierno o sea yo creo que si tú miras
las dictaduras ahora son empresariales o
sea casi todos los nuevos nuevos
presidentes son empresarios o han sido
empresarios
piñera en chile
de brasil
sí
y ya ya ya no necesitan digamos la
presencia de los militares ya hicieron
ese trabajo está hecho y ahora se maneja
con el dinero y con los dos sí fíjate
que en chile por ejemplo uno de los
grandes miedos ahora es perder el
trabajo ese es el gran miedo y el miedo
general en cualquier lugar donde estés
si pierdes tu trabajo te encuentras un
usuario problema y se sienten amenazados
por eso y además digamos hay una
mentalidad de ya nadie es completamente
necesario nadie es irremplazable
esta persona puede ser muy buena pero yo
mañana me consigue ahora estará todo
este tipo de conducción política que por
supuesto pues tiene objetivos muy
concretos económicamente hablando es
decir beneficiar siempre a los que más
tienen en general necesita también de
una fuerza policial para mantenerse no
pero que está en segundo plano no no
está
están ocupados empiezan a salir también
claro se trata de represión finalmente
pero después digamos
bueno el tiempo está pasando como agua
entre los dedos es increíble yo siempre
me quedo lelo y admirado y estupefacto
de ver la forma de cobro revertido esto
tiene que ver con el teléfono sí
básicamente porque el tipo que usa el
teléfono no tiene dinero para llevar a
su casa en chile entonces lo hace todo
cobro revertido
incluso las llamadas en montreal
las hace también acabaron reversión hay
una secuencia muy entretenida una
película argentina de exiliados
argentinos en parís que se las arreglan
para
que un teléfono les permite hablar al
mundo continuamente sin pagar sí sí pero
eso fue así acá acá había uno que tenía
un número mágico y argentina
yo vivía en san luís en la época de
entel empresa nacional de
telecomunicaciones y había más de un tal
dembélé y estaban las viejas cabinas
telefónicas en la calle y lo que hacían
eran pinchaban los teléfonos era con un
acierto
mismo cable citó con dos cocodrilos y lo
ponían en cierto lugar de teléfono
cierto lugar y había uno se da cuenta
cuando había un teléfono pinchado porque
había san luís en una ciudad de
estudiante es una ciudad estudiantes y
había colas de 50 60 70 metros de
estudiantes entonces tenían un límite de
15 minutos cada uno para hablar con sus
familiares y había una cola esperando
para ese teléfono 5 superar para un tal
para la marcha cada un tal por entel
hay algún comentario bueno entonces muy
rápidamente porque se nos fue el tiempo
leonora vamos a resaltar los temas que
queremos que nuestros oyentes no vayan a
visitar nuestro sitio y tú nos habla de
la inclaudicable búsqueda de justicia de
michelle que ver a michelle quevedo es
una joven mexicana es margarita michelle
quevedo orozco que estuvo recientemente
en ottawa con un grupo de personas
representantes de grupos de derechos
humanos de méxico en la historia de
michelle es una historia muy trágica es
una historia que tiene que ver con su
familia y la delincuencia común en
mexico
ella es de veracruz y su hermano de 18
años fue secuestrado en veracruz y
pidieron rescate y entonces pagaron y no
aparecía el hermano el hermano menor de
15 años y el novio de ella en ese
momento de 25 supieron dónde estaba les
avisaron fueron a buscar y los balearon
y los mataron y después su hermano que
había desaparecido apareció cuatro años
más tarde
el cadáver los huesos que encontraron
médicos forenses de argentina estos
grupos que buscan identificar a las
personas que bueno los restos de las
personas entonces es una historia muy
gráfica pero al mismo tiempo es una
historia de donde mucha de mucha fe de
mucho de mucha fuerza por parte de todos
y a pesar de todo eso ella es licenciada
en comercio internacional pero ahora
está terminando una carrera de
criminalística que le permite trabajar
con los grupos en investigación buscando
a donde están los desaparecidos
ella es forma parte del movimiento por
nuestros desaparecidos en méxico y bueno
para saber cómo le fue en ottawa y cómo
va la cosa pues en méxico hay que
escuchar la entrevista de rainer punto o
sea rápidamente la entrevista y samantha
garcía que es un estudiante de derecho
de la universidad mcgill ella participó
de unas jornadas que se llevaron a cabo
el último domingo y lunes ante el
parlamento en ottawa en el que tomaron
parte 68 estudiantes de derechos de
varias universidades canadienses de tres
provincias de canadá para
y la modificación de las leyes y normas
que rigen el refugio en este país porque
al entender de ellos la entidad de
abogados que patrocinó esta actividad
hay demasiadas trabas para que los
refugiados puedan seguir viviendo de
manera tranquila e incluso acceder a la
residencia permanente entonces piden que
esas normas sean revistas y que se
incluyan las modificaciones pertinentes
sirvió además de un ensayo para que los
futuros abogados puedan ejercitarse en
el ejercicio de la defensa de los
refugiados
rcn punto osea leonardo gimeno las
tendencias de la conferencia mundial de
la movilidad si en realidad hace un par
de años se venía haciendo este este
encuentro en barcelona en españa es un
encuentro donde las grandes empresas de
comunicaciones presentan todo lo
relativo a la comunicación
particularmente telefónica y otros tipos
de comunicación pero este año ninguna de
las grandes empresas presentó sus nuevos
móviles sus caballitos de batalla sino
lo que presentaron fueron tecnologías es
decir la inteligencia artificial dentro
de los teléfonos
de los autos la nueva y es tan esperada
red 5g que va a solucionar un montón de
problemas de tráfico de congestión de
datos que existen en este momento en el
montaje muy bien yo por mi parte los
invito a escuchar una entrevista que
hice esta semana con lila downs lila
downs que se presenta el próximo domingo
10 de marzo en la ciudad de vancouver
ella va a presentar va a ser un
espectáculo con temas de su último álbum
que se llama salón lágrimas y deseo con
el que ganó un grammy latino el año
pasado y es ella dedica ese disco a la
mujer a la mujer latinoamericana pero a
todas las mujeres en el mundo y además
se les dedica un tema aa
nvidia se llama el tema se lo dedica a
trump y sus compinches allí
bueno y desafortunadamente se fue todo
el tiempo de que disponíamos para este
castor cibernético en el mensaje
hablando de la onda corta javier
gonzález nunca nos dice yo estaba
registrado en el envío automático del
boletín de programas de frecuencia de
radio que es internacional inclusive
tengo algunos guardados como recuerdo
bueno excelente muchísimas gracias a
todos ustedes allá en el ciberespacio
gracias a josé leandro urbina
muchísimas gracias por la visita a
qantas paz y diagnóstico y chantal
extenso ver los controles técnicos en la
versión web de este programa van a
escuchar la música que no pudimos
escuchar y estar a cargo de lo decíamos
de simple plan así de que el tiempo se
nos fue no nos podemos despedir sin
saludar a la gente que nos ha supuesto
saludar y esperamos cuando los billetes
muestra sobre un botón a mí me
encantaría una muestra de esos billetes
bueno eso fue todo para este castor
cibernético este viernes 2 de marzo
adiós y hasta la próxima chau